I don’t know why but I always enjoyed listening
to christmas Carols. Maybe it’s due to their
connection with my favourite season or maybe
they’re just good songs, i don’t know.
But with that said if I had to pick my favorite,
I will probably have to go with “Good King
Wenceslas” , after all it’s very well
known even being sung by the soldiers in the
christmas truce. But to specify, when i said
“Good King Wenceslas” I meant that I like
the translated czech version not the english
one …
But wait hold on, translated in to Czech?
Isn’t Wenceslas a Czech king, … hhmm yehhh
he is, well not this one, or this, or this
one, not any of them, in fact the king we
call the Good King Wenceslas or also known
as St. Wenceslas the patron saint of Czech
Lands lived in the 10th century and was the
first king of Bohemia ever to be called Wenceslas,
So all these other guys are just posers.
But digress, now that we know which Wenceslau
of bohemia the song is talking about, why
isn’t the original carol in Czech? Well
for that we will have to do some extensive
digging as the answer isn’t as simple as
you may think. So to start off we will have
to skip St Wenceslaus actual life in the 10th
century as the origin of the carol surprisingly
doesn’t start with him. It was in fact during
the high middle ages around the early 13th
century when the melody and the trochaic meter
of the song was created, but it wasn’t a
christmas carol. It was a latin spring song
called "Tempus adest floridum" which talked
about blooming flowers and the coming of warmth
right after the frost of winter. This song
wasn’t written down for much of its early
existence so no one really knows where it
came from. But this is how it sounded like
…
So pretty much very similar to the Wenceslau
Carol today just with different words.
Continuing on from there Tempus adest Floridum
was finally written down in Finland around
the 16th century in to a book called Piae
Cantiones. This book which was a collection
of multiple medieval songs eventually found
its way to England where in the 19th century
it came in to the hands of John Mason Neale.
He was known in England as a devout christian,
hymn writer and specially a hymn translator
of old latin medieval texts. And this is where
Tempus adest floridum comes in to play, as
he is the one who took the melody of that
song and used it for a christmas song he wrote
called “Good King Wenceslas”. He then
published this song in 1853 which was meat
with mixed results, however over time it became
one of the most well known christmas carols
not just in the English speaking world but
also in the rest of Europe.
So when does Czech come in to play to any
of this? Well if you look closely on the wikipedia
article for the Good King Wenceslas carol,
there’s a sentence mentioning that, According
to older Czech sources, Neale's lyrics are
a translation of a poem by Czech poet Václav
Alois Svoboda, written in Czech, German and
Latin. Why those three languages you ask,
well because Bohemia was part of the Austro-Hungarian
empire, and if you wrote something in czech
you also had to write it at least in German
and Latin so other people in the Empire could
read it. But I digress, again. Continuing
from there in true wikipedia fashion when
you click the source for this sentence the
page doesn’t exist.
Does this mean that the Czechs just made this
up so they could lay some sort of a hypothetical
claim to a popular english christmas carol
about their old king. Well that’s what I
thought after googling for the original poem
written by Vaclav and only coming across numerous
pages like this one on duolingo where even
people from Czech republic where unable to
find the original poem. With my luck being
no different, I was almost about to decide
that the poem was just made up Czech Propaganda
and leave it at that.
But then I came across this book written in
Czech in 1902 where on the page 208 the writer
complains about Vaclav not getting any credit
for writing the original “Good King Wenceslas”
poem in 1847 which would be 6 years before
Neals publication of his carol. The writer
goes on to sight his source where he names
the poem in german Sanct Wenzel und Podiwini.
Which means Saint Wenceslas and Podiwin ? Whatever
that is.
But now I have a source, so I can just plug
this in to google and find the original. Well
turns out no. Because even mighty google has
no idea what this source means. Even if you
just put in the supposed german name of the
poem, nothing turns out. So now I am back
to square one as the Austrian, Czech, German
and Oxford online library archives along with
google turn out nothing when you type in the
supposed name of the poem outside of that
one book that is referencing it.
But at this point I am not willing to give
up just yet. I decided to change my approach
from searching just for the poem to searching
for the author of the poem. Although at that
moment I realized I completely forgot to address
the problem every Austro-Hungarian scholar
faces and that is multiple names and variations
of names for one thing. So when it came to
the author of our supposed poem, turns out
he had 15+ different variations of his name.
These variations weren’t large but when
dealing with library databases a single letter
change can make a big difference. Plus, the
authors first name Vaclav is the Czech name
from which the english Wenceslas is derived
from. So I am searching for a poem with king
named Wenceslas and the writer named Wenceslas.
Or Wenceslas and Vaclav, or Vaclac and Vaclav?
Nein, er heißt Wenzel. Nie ma na imię Wacław.
Nem a neve Wenceshlaus. (slures) Pred oknom,
za oknom, stoji mikulas, povedz nam dedusko
… ha co tu vsetci robyte ? Aghhhhh, lets
go back to the drawing board.
Now we know there’s multiple variations
for not just the name of the author but also
the poem. So we could have just been searching
with a bad variation of the poem's name. I
quickly write out some plausible name variations
and go back to the aforementioned online databases.
I still have no luck finding the exact poem
but I do find numerous amounts of writings
mentioning or referencing the 1847 Wenceslas
poem. I also find that Podivin isn’t a weird
german word but an actual name of the king's
favorite servant in the 10th century. I even
manage to find the book keepings of either
a Prague based publisher or just a bookseller
(I can’t tell) selling the Sanct Wenzeslaw
und Podiwin poem for 10 Austro-Hungarian crowns
in 1847. Now finally convinced the actual
poem exists, I am poised to finally find it.
So at this point it’s time to turn to my
last plan which is searching for all the different
variations of the authors name and then looking
if one of the works that come up is the Good
King Wenceslas poem. I go to the Austrian
National library first, and nothing. I then
go to the Czech national library and after
a few tries of different name variations I
finally find the Czech and German version
of the poem. But, i can’t see them, because
they’re not digitised. I can however schedule
a meeting and fly to Prague to see the works
with my own eyes … apparently.
This is so weird. You complain for a Czech
not getting credit for creating the original
Good King Wenceslas poem but then hide the
actual original poems from anyone reading
it. You don’t have to take pictures of the
originals if it will ruin them, at least write
them down on a blog post or something so we
can at least see what the original poem says
… Unless, it doesn’t actually exist. Yes
there are many references citing the poem,
but we never seen the original. Maybe this
is just a weird cycle where everybody is references
something that doesn’t actually exist. And
it got to such a point that the Czech National
library mentions the poems under the writers
creations without really looking if they actually
have them. Brushing it off as in ou it’s
in just an old pile of books somewhere maybe.
But they don’t actually have it. That would
be crazy, that would never happen, right?
Well, actually, in this case it didn’t happen.
How do I know. Because even though I haven't
seen the original poem a week later I managed
to find an 1847 Austrian Yearbook for teachers,
parents and educators which along with math
problems and other things that teachers would
like has the German version of Vaclav Alois
Svoboda’s Sanct Wenceſlaw und Podiwin poem,
published that same year.
Now finally that we have the poem we can look
if Neal actually just translated Vaclav’s
poem or created his own song. Disclaimer keep
in mind my German isn’t great but I’ll
try my best.
What we can say for sure just from the first
look is that Neal didn’t just straight up
translate the poem into english and that was
that, this is because Neal’s carol has only
5 stanzas where as Vaclav’s poem has 3 verses
together numbering in 26 stanzas. Plus Neal’s
carol has an alternate rhyming scheme (ABABCDCD...)
as opposed to Vaclav’s poem which has 2
different rhyming schemes starting with a
couplet (AABBCC…) which then switches in
to an alternate. This means without alterations
Vaclav’s poem couldn’t even be sung to
the good King Wenceslas tune.
However when you start looking at the context
of the poem, that’s where things get interesting.
Both works start of with a clear moonlit night
with snow on the ground. Both have the King
Looking out of his Window, Both have the King
Spotting some poor person/people struggling
in the winter night, both have the king deciding
he needs to help the said poor person/people,
both a servant helping the king carry wine,
food and wood, to the poor person/people both
have the servant struggling to move any longer
in the cold and both have the king telling
the servant to walk in his footsteps as it
will be easier for him.
In conclusion it seems too coincidental for
there to be so many similarities between these
two works. Therefore it’s safe to say that
Neal definitely took the story of Good King
Wenceslas from Vaclav’s poem. After that,
he shortened it, altered it to fit the tune
and published it, without crediting or even
mentioning Vaclav at all.
So next time when you hear the Good King Wenceslas
carol you’ll know it’s a story about a
10th century Bohemian king from a 19th century
czech poet altered by an English hymn writer
to fit a 13th century spring tune.
I have promised for a while now that I’ll
do a QnA when I reach 10k subscribers and
since it looks like I should reach that milestone
in January I have decided that my January
video is going to be a QnA. So if you want
to ask me a Question there’s a link to a
google form in the description, please don’t
leave your questions in the comment section
or on Twitter, I will only answer the Questions
from the google form. I hope you enjoyed my
Christmas special video, please consider supporting
me on Patreon and I also have a YouTube History
podcast with Cogito you can listen to. Merry
Christmas.